mais
et parisiens vont avoir à changer leur
d'horaires pour se rendre à l'olympe
après une expérience de charles aznavour
eddy mitchell va donner fait équipe à la
18h30
c'est le vrai départ d'une nouvelle
formule dont bruno coquatrix nous donne
la raison parce que ce sont les heures
qui me restent libres
déjà le spectacle normal si je peux dire
a lieu à 9h30 car je me suis rendu
compte que leurs ennemis les huit
meilleurs que nos moeurs et ça nous
laisse la possibilité sur un spectacle à
6h30
mais on parle justement d'une pénurie de
vedettes
or là vous allez utiliser deux vedettes
par soir une pour le récital de 6h30 et
une pour le spectacle mais n'y a pas une
pénurie de vedettes disons simplement
que il y à des vedettes qui ne peuvent
pas mener toujours leur carrière comme
elles devraient le faire parce que elles
n'ont pas les moyens de le faire et
peut-être justement que l'olympien
deuxième formule va leur permettre à
cela justement il y aurait été plus
défavorisés de mener mieux leur carrière
on nous madame jeunes
ce matin ma voix vous apporter la deux
c'est moi
le fait d'avoir créé un nombre de
représentations supplémentaires l'un
pierre puisque nous avons passé de 2 300
à quelques représentations assistant
parents même peut-être davantage c'est
en fait créé un second d'établissement
un nouvel établissement à paris des 2000
places
un passé par ce geste d'appui vivante et
jeudi
je
où